[Música]
y llegó el momento de revista de prensa
con rosa parés masdéu rosa feliz en
miércoles ya mitad de semana vamos a
empezar entonces hablando de el 'new
york times' porque dice viviendo con el
código en china los controles de la
erakovic pueden sobrevivir al virus que
dice este artículo rosa dónde vemos en
él pues este artículo defiende la tesis
a través de distintos testimonios que
están citados a lo largo de este pues el
texto tan extenso que si jean ping ha
reforzado sus poderes de rastrear y
acarrear a las personas a los ciudadanos
chinos
pues desde que comenzó la pandemia hace
dos años y desde el primer confinamiento
de wuhan y que lo ha hecho mediante una
altísima tecnología punta y citan como
punto de inflexión en esta pues
extensión del sistema de control el
llamado código sanitario de aquí pues el
título del texto este código esta
aplicación que permite a los ciudadanos
chinos ingresar en ciertos espacios
públicos en función de la información
que tienen las después de salud no sobre
las personas dice que si bien este
sistema de control gozó de cierta
popularidad y aceptación entre la
población pues durante la pandemia
alabando la forma como las autoridades
chinas habían conseguido pues atajar un
poco la crisis sanitaria que preocupa
ahora que se instrumentalice este
sistema de vigilancia para perseguir
entre otras cosas a la disidencia no que
persista este sistema de control y de
hecho hay dos abogados que se califican
a sí mismos como disidentes opuestos a
la partido comunista que ya explican
como las autoridades les han impedido
ciertos viajes de trabajo mediante la
manipulación de esta aplicación rosa
vamos ahora con una polémica que hay
actualmente en eeuu de la cadena y vice
news que anunció la suspensión temporal
del humorista whoopi goldberg del
programa the view a qué se debe esto
rosa viena se enmarca esta polémica en
la discusión que tenía lugar en la
programa que presenta esta cómica en la
cadena davis y pues en las que se
comentaba prohibición un tema que salió
la semana pasada de la novela gráfica
mouse que aborda el tema del holocausto
en un distrito escolar de tennessee bien
la humorista dijo en el marco de esta
conversación que no se podía considerar
el holocausto como un tema racial sino
que tuvo lugar entre dos grupos de
personas blancas y que el holocausto fue
una cuestión de la inhumanidad de
hombres contra hombres evidentemente
este comentario levantó muchísima
indignación entre otras pues entre
usuarios individuales y entre
organizacionales como el auschwitz
memorial o stop antisemitismo que
calificaron los comentarios de
peligrosos acto seguido pues whoopy
goldberg se disculpó en redes sociales
como en el mismo programa al día
siguiente dijo como dijo jonathan
greenblatt de la liga antidifamación el
holocausto fue la aniquilación
sistemática del pueblo judío por parte
de los nazis
que los consideraban una raza inferior
me corrijo sin embargo la cadena ha
decidido suspender a la humorista
durante dos semanas dijo para que
reflexionar sobre sus comentarios
equivocados e hirientes y hemos querido
pues seleccionar un párrafo de the
gardian que al abordar esta polémica
recuerda los nazis consideraban a los
judíos como una raza inferior y una
amenaza para los alemanes para los
alemanes arios se utilizó una ideología
racista para justificar la aniquilación
de cualquier persona con ascendencia
judía independientemente de sus
creencias y prácticas religiosas en el
mein kampf el propio hitler describió al
pueblo judío como una raza no como una
religión rosa y cerramos con una noticia
que se ha hecho viral a nivel
internacional porque es que una mujer
denunció que su avatar fue violado en el
metaverso exacto se trata de una noticia
que encontramos publicada en medios de
comunicación de alrededor del mundo y
que aborda precisamente el comentario
que hizo una mujer británica de 43 años
en su propio blog y que luego pues
explico más detalladamente en la revista
the mail on sunday bien ella explicó que
tras estar 60 segundos en un juego
llamado horizon propiedad de meta antes
conocido como facebook el grupo de marck
zuckerberg fue agredida sexualmente por
un grupo de avatares masculinos con una
voz masculina y a pesar de que se quitó
inmediatamente el casco de realidad
virtual sufre ansiedad desde entonces
a partir de este caso el business
insider contacta con meta para pedir una
explicación una reacción a esta denuncia
y la empresa de mark zuckerberg
respondió lamentamos lo sucedido
queremos que en orís on the news todo el
mundo tenga una experiencia positiva y
que encuentren fácilmente las
herramientas de seguridad que puedan
ayudar en una situación como ésta y que
nos ayuden a investigar ya tomar medidas
pero esta es la clave un poco raúl
porque como más inmersivas no sean estas
experiencias y como más indisociable sea
el mundo virtual del físico pues más
urgente es el debate de determinar quién
y cómo debe regular estos espacios no
raúl hoy vemos todo lo de la sociedad lo
bueno y lo humano lo malo rosa
muchísimas gracias entonces por toda la
información nos vemos mañana con más de
revista de prensa vamos a saludar ahora
nuestro primer invitado al día
[Música]